نبدا كواليس مع اخبار جميله لمحبين النجم
العالمي جيرارد بتلر حيث عرفنا في كواليس
انه عمليات ما بعد الانتاج لفيلمو قدهار
انتهت في انتظار عرضه في 2023 بحسب مصادر
صحفيه امريكيه الفيلم الاوائل الافلام
الامريكيه اللي جرى التصويرها بالكامل في
مدينه العلا التاريخيه شمال غرب السعوديه
ويلعب بتلر دور مهم في الفيلم وهو دور
العميل السري توم هارس في الاخراج
بناء على تجاربه في وكاله الاستخبارات في
افغانستان تجربتنا في الفيلم
التجربه رائعه وفريده من نوعها
اكثر من اللي بتصور في الشرق الاوسط طبعا
عالم يعني تنتقل لعالم مختلف من نوعيه
الانتاج كيفيه الانتاج الميزانيه طبعا
الجوده
الموارد كلها اللي كانت تحت يدنا فهي من
اروع التجارب الصراحه
[موسيقى]
قبل
انتهاء القاهره من بطوله الهام علي واحد
صقر الى ان الجمهور ينتظر وحتى الان اي
اخبار عن الفيلم اللي لم يعد يتحدث عنه
احد من صناعه تم تصويره بالكامل في
القاهره الاكثر من ثلاث اشهر في العديد من
مواقع التصوير الداخليه والخارجيه وتدور
احداثه في اطار دراما الرعب او التشويق
وهو من تاليف احمد الملاواني واخراج محمود
كامل كان لنا لقاء مع الهام علي اللي
سالناها تحديدا عن هذا الفيلم ولي يبدو
انه مصيره مجهول حتى بالنسبه له بالنسبه
للفيلم همم هو فعلا تم الانتهاء هذا
الفيلم الاجنبي يعني انا وزوجي همم الفنان
خالد صقر فرحانه بهذا الفيلم سبب عدم
العرض الى الان اعتقد هذا الامر عند همم
الاداره المنتجه لهذا الفيلم
اذا كانت راح تتواجد في النسخه الجديده من
طاش اللي تعيدها الثنائيه الشهيره عبد
الله السدحان وناصر القصبي سويا من جديد
انا مره فرحانه بتجربه طاش ما طاش صراحه
اتمنى كل التوفيق يا ساتذتنا الاستاذ ناصر
القصبي والاستاذ عبد الله السدحان فرحان
جدا بهذه التجربه بهذه العوده كلنا شغف
لاحياء الذكريات الجميله اللي تربينا
عليها همم هل اكون انا متواجده او لا هذه
الاعلام عند الله انه راح اصرح صراحه لان
الى الامن ده ما في توقيع رسمي ما اقدر
الصراحه بس هل تتمنى اكيد اتشرف بهذا
الشيء
جد الكبير ولاحق فنانين المهرجانات في
الوطن العربي مع كل خطوه جديده يقوم بها
يقاومون بمساعده نجوم اخرين من الوسطين
الغنائي والدرامي اخر هؤلاء الفنانين
واللي تحتضنوا ويسرى في مسلسلها الحمد لله
على السلامه المقرر عرضه في رمضان المقبل
عندنا بقى راح يقدم شخصيه محوريه في احداث
المسلسل ويقوم بدور ابن الفنانه يسرا اللي
يعمل على سياره يبيع عليها مشروبات ساخنه
يشاركوا طبعا في البطوله المسلسل عدد من
الفنانين الشباب منهم السيد شيماء سيف وهو
طبعا من اخراج عمرو صلاح كواليس كان لها
هذا اللقاء معنبه الى اصبح عندنا فضول
نتعرف على اكثر وعلى بعض
الفنيه
في ناس كثيره ما كانتش مصدقه الموضوع زي
تماما بس همم ناس طلعت تكلمت و اثبتت
الموضوع ده مش باغني مهرجانات زي ما
بداوها الناس اللي غنت مهرجانات انا باغني
يعني حاجه جديده منها بين الراب وبين
المهرجان الفلوس اللي بتيجي لي باروح اسجل
بها فلوس كلها مزيكا
احنا هنتعلم في المدرسه حاجات كثيره بس
الشارع اكبر مدرسه ده اللي تعلمته الدنيا
دي اكبر مدرسه
يعني مش كل حاجه تبقى في الورقه والقلم
خالص
[موسيقى]
عام 2022 نلاحظ انها لم تحمل مره اسم اي
فيلم سعودي ضمن الافلام العشره الا مره
واحده طبعا نقصد الافلام العشره الاكثر
اقبالا رغم انه الافلام كانت بتسعه تسعه
افلام سعوديه مرت على الشباك هذا العام
وهي قريعه ابطال 90 يوم سكه طويله كيان
جنون حياه امراه والان 16 بينما استطاع في
السعوديه واحد التواجد في هذه القائمه مره
في 22 وهو الروح الزرقاء عن نادي الهلال
السعودي
على مهرجان افلام السعوديه عم بدات
التسجيل لدوريته التاسعه والمستمر حتى 8
مارس 2023 حيث يعقد المهرجان بمركز اثراء
بالظهران في ما يقادم واللي تنضم الجمعيات
السينما بالشراكه مع مركز الملك عبد
العزيز الثقافي العالمي اثراء وبدعم من
هيئه الافلام التابعه لوزاره الثقافه يضمن
المهرجان في دورته القادمه وهي التاسعه
التنافس على اربع مسابقات وهي مسابقه
الافلام الطويله مسابقه الافلام القصيره
مسابقه الافلام الوثائقيه ومسابقه
السيناري وغير المنفذ بينما تتنافس ام
مشاركه الافلام والسيناريو على 26 الجائزه
المهرجان طبعا اكتسب قيمه واهميه كبيره
على مستوى المنطقه والسبب انه من الدوره
الماضيه بدات تدخل الافلام الخليجيه كمان
الى المنافسه
[موسيقى]